YEN-JIE LEE: Before people
take 8.03 class, especially
my version, most
of the students may
think uncertainty principle
is actually completely related
to quantum mechanics.
So actually it is
actually not the case.
Actually, uncertainty
principle almost have nothing
to do with quantum mechanics.
It has to do with just the
wave description we employ
when we describe the system.
So that's actually
one of the big thing
which you will learn from 8.03.
The other thing which
people will learn a lot more
is actually that before
they come into the class,
they may think it's almost
impossible to understand
infinitely number of
coupled oscillators.
And it turns out that there
is a very systematical way
you can actually make use
of simple symmetry argument,
and that you can
actually greatly simplify
complicated system, like
infinity long system.
So it is actually not
an impossible task,
and then everything can
be actually understand,
using the concept of symmetry,
which we introduce in 8.03.